-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here. You're watching.
Thank you very much.
Well, guys, as the war in
Ukraine continues,
everyone has a theory about how
to resolve the conflict.
Well, this weekend,
former president Trump
had an interesting idea.
He said that the U.S.
should paint Chinese flags
on its planes
and then bomb Russia.
So, if you're wondering what
Trump has been up to lately,
the answer is huffing glue.
I don't know.
These are the types of ideas
you come up with
after you stare at the sun
too long.
Do you know what
I'm talking about?
This is...
Then Trump said that
he would stop Russian tanks
by painting a tunnel
on the side of a mountain
so they slam into it.
[ As Trump ] Meep-meep.
[ Normal voice ] And get this.
On Saturday,
Ukrainian President Zelensky
held a Zoom call
with U.S. lawmakers.
And at one point
during the meeting,
he asked Florida Senator
Rick Scott to mute himself.
You all know Senator Rick Scott
from Florida.
Yeah.
Zelensky was like, "And you can
turn your camera off, too,
if you want to."
It's amazing.
With everything Zelensky
is dealing with, even he's like,
"Freaking Florida.
You know what I'm saying?"
Yeah, it turns out there was
a guy in the back of
Rick Scott's Zoom yelling,
"Tell him about my
painted-planes idea."
Well, as companies continue to
distance themselves from Russia,
TikTok just announced
that users in the country
can no longer post videos.
Yep, when they heard
TikTok was banned,
Russians were like...
-♪ Oh, nyet ♪
♪ Oh, nyet ♪
♪ Oh, nyet, nyet, nyet, nyet ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Oh, nyet."
-It's topical.
That's nice. Come on.
-Yeah, no TikTok, Facebook,
or Twitter.
Right now,
Tom from MySpace is like,
"Well, well, well,
look who came crawling back."
Meanwhile here in the U.S.,
a convoy of truckers
spent the last two days circling
the Capital Beltway
outside D.C.
to protest COVID restrictions.
Yep, the truckers waited
until all the mandates
were lifted and gas hit 5 bucks
a gallon, so great timing.
Let's change gears.
"The Batman" just had
a huge opening weekend.
Did you see it?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, it was good.
One theater in Texas
had an unexpected issue
during a screening of the movie.
Watch this.
-During a showing of
the new movie "The Batman"
this weekend in Austin,
an actual bat
infiltrated the theater.
-At first,
people were like, "Finally.
3-D without the glasses.
They've done it!
They figured it out!"
It got weird when, a few minutes
later, a penguin waddled inside.
They're like, "What the hell
is happening here?"
In the end,
they got the bat to leave
by telling him the movie
was three hours long.
He's like, "I got things to do."
I got things to do."
Some more entertainment news.
Last night, a new reality dating
show called "The Courtship"
premiered on NBC,
and it's being described as
a mix between "The Bachelor"
and "Bridgerton."
But unlike "The Bachelor,"
the only disease they get
from the hot tub is scurvy.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
Yeah, it's a fun idea, although
the romance takes a while
to get going because every piece
of clothing has 125 buttons.
And, finally, the world's
largest cruise ship
just set sail
on its first voyage.
The ship is called
the "Wonder of the Seas"
and is five times bigger than
the "Titanic."
Meanwhile, passengers are like,
"Cool, but let's maybe not
compare any ship
to the 'Titanic,' okay?"
We have a great show.